hi I'm Erik Bosse and recent Avengers
endgame footage has shown us how they
enosis snap effect they'd be of interest
personally in Citi Field home of the
Mets but what about a place that isn't
used to tragic losses Wakanda the most
technologically advanced nation on earth
became the planet's new ground zero and
infinity war giving Black Panthers crew
a unique role in the wars to come it
seems like in Baku and Okoye I survived
the snap
what about Sherita chocolate sister
credited as the world's smartest
engineer what happened to her where
could she be she did I'm gonna break
down four theories for sure he's fate
and what her story could be an end game
and beyond and spoiler warning in case I
get anything right and ruin your life
okay the last time we saw Sheree was
during the battle of a continent
Avengers infinity war she was in the lab
trying to detach the mind stone from
visions head without killing him
rerouting his neurons but then the
Corvus glaive of Thanos's black order
broke in and attacked knocking her down
to the lower level lying motionless on
the floor was the last time we saw
Sheree and how I last saw my uncle
poriyal body sure he didn't show up in
the dust montage and shortly after the
movie came out the Russo brothers said
that confirming whether or not she
survived would be a spoiler ban a few
months back the first trailer for
Avengers endgame included this shot
showing Bruce Banner holding his head
has various faces appear on screen Peter
Parker Scott Lang and Sheree the rent
letters near Scott's name read missing
it's a little hard to tell with Peter
and Sheree but those red words do look
like missing as well we can assume that
these three are all on a list of people
whose fates of surviving Avengers aren't
sure about Scott was trapped in the
quantum realm at the time of the snap
Peter Justin on Titan and I don't think
anyone saw him board the Q ships they
probably just don't know where he is
but sharees fate is more mysterious and
I see four possibilities Gary one sure
he died she was alone when the snap
occurred so it's entirely possible that
she just dusted without a witness and
those dust particles tend to blend in
with the ground without really a trace
so it's not like mbaku could have
stepped in a death spiral and been like
Oh wake boat he got Cherie to but if
that's the case why all the mystery with
the Russos spoiler quote the missing
designation
I think Rab sense has a bigger
importance to it so Gary - sure he
survived but what Conda is back off the
grid think about it for thousands of
years the nation of Wakanda existed in
relatives
krisi to the rest of the world and
pretty much everyone Condon preferred it
that way
well kinda only revealed its true
existence of the rest of the world a
couple of years ago around the events of
civil war and black panther and then
what happened after that
well King T'Challa let the Avengers stow
a Hell in the Troy within their walls
lurking the mad Titan and his army to
bring their fight to their own Wakanda
lost hundreds if not thousands of
warriors on top of the additional 50%
Universal Death wave so arguably
wakanda's cost for coming out of the
shadows was to suffer a fate worse than
any other nation on earth so I could
definitely see what kind of deciding to
return to its isolationist stance turn
away and grieve and try to rebuild on
its own and if what kind of says we
don't exist anymore by the fates of
everyone in Wakanda would be unknown
just like sharees now some said that
with two challahs death Shuri would be
next in line to rise to the throne but
remember the line of succession of what
Conda isn't that simple Shuri would have
to defeat any challengers that warrior
falls without using a naver gizmos and I
think someone like mbaku would be a much
more respected leader to the survivable
countenance that mountain tribe has
always been the most closed off of the
wakandan tribes so when this post snap
world's moon bakas values might be a
more pragmatic answer to people just
like how in real life when a major storm
F's up in your neighborhood you got to
turn to the psycho up on the hill with
bones on his walls on top of that I
could see what Condon's blaming T'Challa
and his whole family for not protecting
them better the same way cap and the
Avengers are probably getting earful
some grieving New Yorkers Shuri might be
missing because she's been banished or
imprisoned or somewhere on the run
but even if the whole nation of Wakanda
goes back off the grid if sure he's
still alive I don't think she would give
up that easily so that leads me to 33
Shuri is helping rebuild the Avengers
sure he can't help but stay busy she's
that tinkerer look how much her eyes lit
up when she met vision she's like mm toy
has come to life she told banner and
Stark how they should have reprogrammed
visions neurons
she's got opinions and these neurons are
fused with vibranium atoms
vibranium being her homegrown material
that she's a world leading expert and
working with so maybe the reason Shuri
is missing is that she's hidden away
trying to rebuild vision actually check
out my past video about the ways vision
could still be alive some have also
taken a closer look at Hawkeye in the
GameTrailers notice how he has new armor
and the material looks tough able to
withstand him sharpening his katana on
that gauntlet could this material be
vibranium and if so could Sheree be
working with Clint as he cuts through
criminals in Japan an entirely plausible
theory but despite sharie's love of
building stuff she's also someone who's
not afraid of the action so 34 story
becomes the next black panther black
panther is of course an established
legacy mantle before T'Challa wore the
suit his father - Chaka did so there's
no reason sure he can't continue the
Black Panther legacy in her brother's
absence she does get a black panther
suit in the comics and we know that she
engineered multiple versions in her lab
look after the snap the world's a mess
boats around
Liberty Island stranded cars and Citi
Field parking lot chaos this kind of
general disarray would lead to more
crime more violence around the world
leaving already disadvantaged people had
even more risk so a post snap earth
doesn't just need Avengers to figure out
some clever way to go back and time and
prevent the snap they also need heroes
to protect them day to day throughout
this dreary post-apocalyptic nightmare
and in that darkness shareed could truly
shine a new black panther who actually
understands the functions of her suits
and mister guard - Tala has been more
like Rhodey or Peter Parker a brave
strong hero but really one plane with a
toy that someone else made for him
whereas Shuri would be like Tony Stark
an engineer behind the wheel of her own
creation what do you want sure he's next
story to be common down below with your
thoughts follow me on twitter instagram
at da boss subscribe to this channel new
rockstars and subscribe to our podcast
where we listen to podcasts if you live
in the LA area come check out my live
nerdy comedy show it's called darkest
timeline comedy our next one is this
Friday March 1st and it's every first
Friday of the month thereafter it's at
the Acme comedy theatre in North
Hollywood ticket info is in the
description below thanks for watching
and since I'm shooting this video before
the Oscar winners are announced
I can't believe Black Panther lost Best
Picture - cream dunk yeah the Oscars are
so biased against popular movies what a
joke
[Music]